Speaker 1: Radical and repugnant. Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE says she was
attacked at a restaurant. She tweeted, quote, I
was attacked in a restaurant tonight by an insane
woman and screamed at by her adult son. They
had no respect for the restaurant or the staff
or the other people dining or people like me who
simply have different political views. They are
self-righteous, insane, and completely out of
control. I was sitting at my table working with
my staff and never even noticed these people
until they turned into demons. People used to
respect others, even if they had different
views. But not anymore. Our country is gone
now. There's a couple of things here that
I think are important to say. First of all,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is a horrible hypocrite.
Here is video of her harassing David Hogg
about his activism out on the street. Yeah.
Speaker 3: David, why are you supporting the red
flag laws? If are then if Scott Peterson, the
resource officer at Parkland, had done his job,
then Nikolas Cruz would have. Anybody in
your high school or at least protected
them. Why are you supporting red flagged
gun laws that attack our Second Amendment.
Speaker 1: Right to remember? Oh, someone
harassed me out in public, which I've also
done to people who are using kids.
Speaker 3: To get at the barrier.
Unidentified: Do you not know how to defend
your stance? Look, I'm an American citizen.
I'm a gun owner. I have a concealed carry
permit I carry a gun with. For myself.
Speaker 3: You are using your lobby
and the money behind it and the kids
to try to take away my Second Amendment right.
Speaker 1: You don't have anything to say for
yourself. All right. You get the picture. So
she's a complete hypocrite. Nobody is allowed to
confront her, but she's allowed to confront other
people. And it's the same thing as always. I do
think there is like a serious discussion about the
entire confronting people in public thing. Now,
this has happened to me. Many of you will remember
about what was it, about a year and a half ago,
I was confronted at a restaurant at an outdoor
seating terrace, I guess you would call it patio,
at a restaurant where a young woman saw
me. And I can kind of tell from across
the room that that she recognized
me. And then as I was leaving,
I get on to the sidewalk and at that point she
yells, David Pakman, you Zionist, Jew bastard.
And I ignored it and just walked away. I mean, I'm
aware of it, obviously, because I told the story,
but I didn't engage with it in any way.
Now, had she done it while I was still
dining and having my beautiful fish and
chips, which I had at that restaurant,
what would I have done? I probably still would
have ignored her. But I do think that if you're
at a restaurant and you're actively harassing a
patron, it would be completely reasonable for the
restaurant to say you can't behave that way or
you've got to leave. Right. So in this situation
where Marjorie Taylor GREENE was harassed, she
says attacked, but it make any indication that
there was anything physical that happened. But
she was harassed as what we could say. It would
be perfectly reasonable for the restaurant to
say, hey, you can't yellin here and you can't
harass people. So you either you either got to
shut up or you've got to leave. Totally, perfectly
reasonable when it comes to the difficulty.
Every time we talk about this is when it comes
to elected officials who earn salaries paid by the
taxpayers. And who choose to evade accountability
of a certain type. You can get to a point where
in your head you say the only way to confront
some of these people might be by doing something
like this. Now, again, I'm not saying I like this
approach or that I am necessarily against it.
I think it's a difficult and complicated thing.
It's come up when we talk about protesting outside
the homes of senators or Supreme Court justices,
and they're sort of like the legal question. But
there's also the moral, moral and ethical thing.
And I'm just not completely sure. I think
there is some gray area. But specifically,
when we're talking about elected officials whose
salaries are paid by taxpayers, I understand that
if they make the decision that they are going
to hide from any kind of public accountability,
you can end up in a situation where there's
no way to even get my point across to this
elected official who salary I pay with my taxes,
other than going up to them in public now, going
up to them in public and screaming insults, if
that's what happened. Not particularly productive
or effective. So let me know your thoughts about
this. But the term attacked that Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is using, at least by everything I've
read, appears to be a bit of an exaggeration